Well,
then, as they presented there, I read
to you about today's talk. It is to talk a little about
what is not going to be because we all came
to learn to learn what things are
good. We come in the afternoon to have a
lot of incredible talks about new
experiments to do perhaps.  you get
it but it's better it's a bit of
hindsight think a little I want to
do and so to zero put
a few things in mind think twice to improve
our project
than to see your engineering vice president
on the side we are a
digital agency that offer different
services  more now pointing to
products it is very interesting how
new projects arrive we find new
solutions for those projects and
customers are happy and more
users who is the final goal
are at blunk on twitter it is
ever on
this talk will be after everyone
jennifer serves later they can't look
there calmly and any doubt that
's right is to buy like twitter  r
for questions or whatever you want
anyway later we chat
first I wanted to congratulate the guys
who organized the first one with faith in
Argentina so congratulations to
all well we come to talk about the ss no
thousand 994 a boost that the css for
the future we had html that  they were texts
a text document but we had to
put a little color note that in
1094 they already think about this parameter
no font-size x 3 we look
but well this was already played in thousand 924 it
will be that the blue color in the links
had more  conversion I was looking for more people and
things I don't know
and there we went to these incredible sites
like science like Argentina which is
a marketing landing let's say sell
sell the event information about the
event who is going to come to chat who is
going to do things
animations incredible things they
did  a site we are
working for fox sports is a news portal a
huge number of articles
information that needs to be done and there are a
lot of things  what we have to take into
account when we
generate a site or not and then a
landing page also for toad marketing what
is that that speaks a little one is to
take the web into the future a novelty if
you do not know the site we made  an
animation system with that you see that with
canvas that was very interesting to
develop later if the client
let's say it was what he expected I don't know
but internally I felt
the development was very interesting at least
then we return to css the voters in
the same sector as they came to  an
element like customizing the properties
ok color text by case all good
and then we have this our code not
that they care because it can't get to
the class because it didn't send
it could and then
I don't know what class convention to use
but then I put many  classes
because to be able to step on the previous one
because it didn't send everything very well
and we finished everything and well nothing came out
ready bye I know if it hits as we say
then  ces let's not try to return that
face of cash well once we
try to think why is this happening how
we can improve a little all our
flow of our project so that this is
not so common at least and improve
all day is a little more  the first thing
to improve and what not to do is improve
our communication as a team as
designers as developers as the
rest of the team nerz product the
client who wants the client who wants
designer to show on the site what
we want as developers to
implement some technology see what
we can achieve  to do it then love
between the whole team project managers
client producers
we are all together developing
something that we have to deliver but as a
team then basic things that are
good that arrive and that do not always
happen in the projects so I want to
do good that if I ask for a  bit
of nole to the designer who has in mind
what the client wants who wants  the
following what is its objective sometimes
many times target browser it is very
good to have stack type analytics chay
who are your most common browsers
so we make sure that 70% of
users have the best experience
now if we still do a we have
some bug right  to a browser an
intra explorer x that because we use it with
banking and people usually use it well
let's make sure we do it well cool that way nobody
has let's say
the upper percentile has errors of
books device of resolutions this for
example the first thing that if the
hd structure wire flips me  that they have in mind
having a layout how it works what
models am I going to use how many pages there are
perhaps it is a landing and it is simpler than
collar they do not need to scale as much in
terms of models and modules but
suddenly we have many and we have to
start reusing them  and think what variations they are
going to have and if we have it from the
first moment or something similar to what one
is going to do, one is going to start  to begin
to understand how to separate those components
how to start working on them a little better
this what a bit of analytics said
no ok chrome 74 percent of users
good public so well let's make sure
that this public receives the best we
can maybe you can use branding box
to  stand out a little more 70 percent
of users are likely to be able to
observe that work that
extra dedication that we are going to give it so taking
this into account, especially resolutions,
is also being able to make a good deal
about those people who are going to receive that
product  well that site
then
one thing that always happens is that the
site is dynamic all the sites are
dynamic dynamic to the point of
responsive I don't even want to say that
I am going to make response sites and it is not
mandatory that is mobile and today it
occupies  a minimum of 50 percent of the
traffic, if not more, on some sites it
reaches 70 to 80 percent mobile,
so this is not an option, it has to
be that way  ne that is good it has to
have half a room what is necessary
even now we are running the base in haro for
about a year we started with
this mobile first design first
we designed alava mobile and then
we started with progress enhancement to
progressively improve the
user experience while it gets bigger  the
screen then the component for
example button without any media query in
reality it is the button as it would be seen in
mobile with the size it will have for
example the background image the
background color and it will have it by
default and then simply when
we start adding  media queries
we will see how that button is going to behave
in the different sizes when we
enlarge it before in the past we started
shrinking it in the distance
here the work the idea or what I propose is
let's start doing it the other way around the
component itself is mobile
then it is always  this we talk about
dynamism do not follow customers and new
guys add two buttons that lead
to  he link to the form to buy
science tickets with easy they have a
great day and on a Sunday morning and they get
up early but then he comes and
tells me no but Sergio the button has
to be red well the problem is
I come red and we are all
happy and I give it to him it is so much on the
page
yes but Sergio was not the one from the bottom who
wanted red not the one from above
all the clients always sometimes they do not
communicate well back the
communication system or it is a matter of perhaps one
is experimenting  with the site while it
finds things so if one thinks it
's the beginning code and starts
adding classes or some selectors
of how it's the best way to work
we do that if we do something like
that they see us much better we're all
happy the client knows that the
bottom button is red it's fine top is the
other color if at first
we were going to put the red button on the top one and we're going to
have problems because he had to do
blue afterwards and the clip changed
so if we have a clean code it
will be simpler material
later but it has the same it also
comes with the content
now we have to translate it and there is no
more button it is I am a button for example
that we want at the end
I am a button and  dot dot dot and
we have to make sure that our
components are scalable not only
in responsible topics but also in
content topics and this often happens
that we don't go but I had put a
fixed height on it and when we do it it breaks because there are
two lines etc. then good  that
is one of the things, let's say, that usually
happens at another point in its structure
to generate a scalable and maintainable site in
the future, it is necessary to generate
a good structure,
a structure where using
processors that I think that today
we should all use for the chips that
brings no matter what that style is it has
that no matter how important it is that
features you need from each of
them sometimes for example me  I think what is
basic is to be able to divide our code
into multiple files to be able to have
a much more maintainable code and that
we know I have to modify the
ok button I go to the button file and touch that
file and with that everything should be
fine so for example we have  you are
sc that is the main thing
where the rest of my bartz components does not matter
where I could bring for example ok
the client said that the blue or the
designer said that the blue was this
blue but suddenly there were
instead styles and they changed the brand and
suddenly blue well this time blue blue
later we have a file of the
component itself
a file structure also in
terms of folders which are
components which are layouts which
are bases which are utilities for
example it goes like this I found a mix
insights which is  very good and that I use it
all the time well I bring it and
save it as my utilities for example
so being very organized with these
points helps here  ue later in our future
our site will be much
easier to maintain
and I think this is one of the most
important things about this is to
put your rules put rules to a
project do not let a project be
loose like pokemons in the city
of  buenos aires that this a jungle does not
decide what the rule is going to be there must
be rules in this but define
yours one of the great point six that is
talked about is if that is not if it is because
skateboarding which is one of the great tokens
of  7 I hope to be very careful with this
because we end up with things like
this that heather main generates
in the why we have to talk about a
submenu of the submenu and but that one had to be
taken out of the collection and we end up with
things like that so how is the great
figure of ssc is a great danger also
in the future for a maintainable site
that is when we see those select ones they make us
a little scared that is why it is
important to generate rules for example
the voters and dinei min but com  or
we are going to call our voters it is
the same if you use is max come or ss it
is irrelevant I chose one or some type of
rule until a set of rules that
serves you and your team and your project
and if it is necessary to throw it away and we have what
we are  a team but as
long as there is consensus and we all keep the
same rules of the project we are
sure that it will always be
maintained in the same way going forward
things like this will happen or that we have to create a
new color as I put it I have gray
gray stronger  lighter gray ok
light gray but not so light because it's
a new color and you end up with this
and then kind of runs head
again
saying sometimes tooling helps a lot on
modern sites in our
modern project we use a lot of
workflows with a lot of your  link with
google with others with with web groups so
that any of these and some things that
we can integrate our workflow for
example that are the cute ones the cute ones
basically ensures  n that the rules that
we define are fulfilled, then if
we decide that a property has a
colon and then a space after the
value of the property, it will be ensured that
the same thing happens on all sides, see
the example that it is half naive, perhaps it is not a
type  well it is the space that matters
if it is a space that matters but
after we have type 300
components 20 of them because our
site started to scale and the client
needs new needs once we
see that any developer who takes over the
site will read the code much more
easy it is not going to start to lose
where it was how was this or what was happening
with it
and something very important I think that only
because the talks call that they do not do the
css and this is important to us
the importance of being the easy solution
to I do not have  time to find the
right way to do it and I have to clean
and make important the house Maria
so let's try to avoid using it and
sometimes if we use it even let  Is there
any documentation of why its use
is important?
Let's try to use iris. It won't use it and
sorry aboitiz. Let's think of
somehow modulating the air. It's something that
cannot be repeated. It's only once on the
site. Imagine if this is why we have
to repeat it because  back there were
changes it's dynamic the world the embi
only had one but after we arrived we
said it's very good it's working
very well let's put another one we have to make
a reactor it's to launch everything back and
that could become a problem you
want to show a little of what  we have been
talking with a module that we have here
we have a letter that has an image
a title a text and then we have
a component that has the ticket of
articles and several options no then
we go a little to the ccs that we would have here
very simply we have the letter that  inside it
has an image an h 3 and a content
but that in rated it is to remove it
behaves differently because although the content
is there it is not shown
now what pro  problems we have here we are
using an android card image what happens
is the content of an image I'm not here
last night 3 analytics arrives tomorrow
we see that the ceo is not doing well that
h 3 has to be an h 2 h 4 when they
are related because it is less  important
and we started back when this factor I
know where this thing was that was happening here
because we did not improve this and well in another
file we have that within the crime it
works another way we have multiple
rules for this now by doing a
little factor we arrive at this that cart a
single  file we don't have multiple
files for this module
it behaves like this has the favors of it
the shadow the border the maximum size
maybe in related it behaves in such a
way and then the different
components of drying carrie plus cards
from the card content this is what I'm going with
think modularly it doesn't matter if
we are going to use is max ssv in to
differentiate that's why its modules the
modules etc. the important thing is that they
have a  to rule and that they manage to follow it
forward
so with this we know that if later
the h2o lh3 h4 or we change it for a
paragraph it will always be consistent
sometimes there is still a change in some
property because the 83 and 82 have
different margins or padin only sizes
but if we feel that they are all
correct in the tulle letter,
we are sure that later when the
site begins to scale and we look at other
modules in other places,
the module will react in the same
way,
something that is always interesting is to
learn from your own code and one
he finishes writing a project to
work in css and starts to do a
little bit of cv he will start to make
different browsers
or different solutions and one begins to
find how look at this I did it this
way 8 and putting this property
changes how it is done in firefox  for
example there are multiple 3ds
ss rendering and you have to be careful with all of them and
the experience you gain by doing this is
exactly what you do  ing a bit of a queue in
our code depending on what
happens in each of them peer review
the pib is a very good practice
for teamwork we learn from the code
of others and what solutions
other people came up with not all
solutions are always  the same and I think it is
something very valuable to share with the
rest of the team that later in the future
even means that the code is
maintained in some way because
we have all already seen that code and we know more or
less what that person is dealing with
here we are in  the office doing a
bit of care on one of the places
that is we are talking about bone dynamism it
is possible it is optional you have to walk
in everything yes or yes and stop tablets how it
works in touch touch it is something it is something
that we had before it is very different how
something works interactively on a
device than a computer
if those are like julia said it has its
problems when they work when they don't
but it is also very important that
new  Our source code if we have hacks or
things that we learned
throughout our development we
document them well because in the
future it will reach another person who
may not be us who has to
maintain that site
and that person will not know why that
property is there and maybe he learns something
new and he says look he's talking about
how in internet explorer the images
looked different
and with this line he solved it I just
learned something new and I think that
developers are people who
are learning things all day  new
because as one showed, there is a
development that is being promoted and that
every time we implement new
technologies to do more incredible things,
new landings, new sites,
new products, everyone here is, let's say,
aiming to
improve what we show the
user experience and that they are
obviously beautiful  no then
thank you all very much now if i'm not mistaken
well in coffee break we also have
p  questions if I'm not mistaken for a little while
I don't know and if I'm not there
to have a coffee or a beer whatever you
like later so thank you
all very much
[Applause]